now it's time to finish creating our new
view by drawing its contents and we do
that within our custom views on draw
method now the Android canvas is pretty
standard as far as canvas api's go uses
a painter's algorithm meaning that each
new thing you paint will cover anything
beneath it the canvas and paint classes
offer a variety of brushes and helpers
to draw and fill lines boxes circles and
texts with colors patterns gradients and
images as well as offering the ability
to move rotate and scale the canvas
while you draw I could spend a lot of
time here detailing exactly how to use
each of these tools but there's nothing
unique to Android and it's covered
really well on the documentation link
below it is possible though to create
pretty advanced UI is this way for
example for example if we start by
drawing a circle and then add a second
circle and then you just need to finish
drawing the rest of the compass here's
an example I prepared earlier the
specifics of what you draw are different
for every view but one thing that is
consistent is the resource constrained
device you're drawing on and that the
ondraw method will be called every time
the screen is refreshed potentially many
times a second that means any object
created here within your on draw method
including things like paint objects will
be created and destroyed at an alarming
frequency object creation and
destruction can be expensive on Android
potentially affecting the smoothness of
your UI when garbage collection is
initiated the solution move the scope of
any object used within the on draw loop
into the class scope go ahead and
override the ondraw method within your
new view and draw the new control in
fact why not take this opportunity to
create a custom control that can display
the wind speed and direction for use
within sunshine once you're done you can
add it to your layout using its full
package name and class name in the XML
like this run it and then post a
screenshot of your new view into the
forum